that's a very good question I think what
the conclusion I've come to about this
is that what you try to do is as far as
possible constrain that rejection ISM
and undermine it religiously as well as
politically in other words what is
helpful in those circumstances is to
have people who from on the one side a
Muslim perspective who will say you know
there there there the sudden and the
Israeli nature of that position is
actually hostile to our our concept of
Islam and then on the other side
obviously you know it's very helpful
often when you get rabbis that will come
out and and say you know this is
completely wrong so for example when
there were some settlers who were trying
to who were gation I think destroying
the Quran or something of that nature
you know there were rabbis that came out
and spoke very strongly from the
perspective of the Jewish faith as to
why this was wrong now you will never
how do you deal with them in the end
there my answer to that is you it you
either persuade them to change or you
defeat them so that's why the most
important role this is why religions got
a part to play in this because actually
the types of leave aside the core who
are rejectionists the outer circle that
might be attracted by that rejection ism
they won't listen to an argument that is
simply about reconciliation as a
political notion right they will only
actually listen to it if it is
religiously grounded and this is why in
dealing with these issues religion you
know and religious that religious faith
is so religious teaching is so important
because if you can't explain to them why
their religion calls the pollen to act
differently they will not act
differently so this is why it's very
important to my answer is you you you
try and limit the appeal and you either
persuade or defeat ultimately but that's
that I think is the only way you can do
it and that's why religious leaders of a
responsibility in this situation can't
opt out of it